Speaker 1: Donald Trump, increasingly seeming
unwell, posting uncontrollably to Truth
social, wrote essential multiple times per hour
about Fox News, about Ron DeSantis, about rhinos,
about CPAC. Trump seems to have nothing to do
other than to rage and meltdown day after day,
hour after hour. Look at the last 24 hours for
Trump untruth, sensual, whatever you call it.
Trump starting yesterday with, quote, I think that
Fox board member Rhino Paul Ryan put his boss,
Rupert Murdoch, in a great legal and monetary
jeopardy by convincing him to go against his
news anchors and their belief that the
2020 presidential election was rigged
and stolen. It was stolen. In so doing, Murdoch
is saying that Fox behaved badly when in fact,
evidence has proven that the election was rife
with election fraud and irregularities. Ryan
is bad luck for Fox. He should resign or be
fired. Too many incompetent rhinos at Fox
News. This. This is freakin brilliant. We have
all of the texts that show that the Fox host
didn't really believe Trump won. This is what's
so amazing about Trump's ability to just ignore
critical realities about the world around us.
Trump wants to make the case. All those Fox
hosts rightly believed that I won. But Rupert
Murdoch and Paul Ryan convinced them otherwise.
The truth is, the anchors were publicly playing
up this whole it was stolen narrative or it was
stolen, as Trump wrote. But privately they
were texting each other about how it was all
B.S. so they didn't really believe it. That's the
reality. But of course, so far, Rhino Paul Ryan.
Rupert Murdoch, That's the target of Trump's ire.
Trump Then moving on to talking about polling,
talking in speaking, typing in all caps, great
poll numbers leading Biden Desanctis and all
others by a lot. Make America Great again.
Okay, so going after Ron DeSantis and Biden.
Trump continuing now. Moving on to CPAC. Now
understand the context. CPAC is a joke this year.
Last night I tried to stream day one. There were
no live streams. It seems like they canceled day.
What? Look, it's it's it's in shambles at CPAC.
Trump is speaking there on Saturday. And Trump is,
I guess, angry that a lot of people aren't
going there or something. So Trump posts,
I will be at CPAC on Saturday talking about the
fact that obviously our capital C country is going
to quote unquote hell and how to fix it. Also,
the Democrats use of radical left prosecutors
and the weaponization of law enforcement it is
illegal, has never been used and abused like this
and has the potential to bring down our once fair
and wonderful capital C country. These Marxists,
cat Marxist capital T thugs have been after me
for years only to help them win elections in
just capital two capital years. We have become a
third world capital F failing capital and nation
MAGA. So just dissembling completely, just his
brain is mush. Trump continuing now addressing
why many aren't going to CPAC. The only reason
certain, quote, candidates won't be going to CPAC
is because the crowds have no interest in anything
they have to say. They've heard it all before
and don't want to hear it again. But my speech on
Saturday night is already a sold out monster. They
are trying to expand the room and space. We'll
have a great time at CPAC. We always do. See you
there. And don't forget to vote in the important
straw poll now. One of the reasons a lot of people
aren't going to CPAC is that CPAC, the guy who
runs CPAC, Matt SCHLAPP, is accused, despite
being anti-gay, is accused of sexually assaulting
a male staffer of Herschel Walker's back during
the campaign. I know that the language is sort of
colorful. But he's accused the word that was used,
his pummeling the junk of one of these staffers.
And a lot of a lot. Some Republicans seem to want
nothing to do with Matt SCHLAPP. Okay. A couple
more posts. And again, this is all within a day.
Trump is just uncontrollably post-truth. Central
essential quote, Rumors are flying high. That
idiot RINO Paul Ryan, who has greatly hurt the
credibility of Rupert Murdoch with his ridiculous
stance that the 2020 election was all peaches
and cream will be fired like a dog from the Fox
board. Fox is going in the wrong direction.
Ratings are heading down and Murdoch just
threw certain very good people who were correct
under the bus. He played right into the enemy's
camp. Viewers and MAGA are not happy. And
then lastly, Trump posting. Rupert Murdoch
should apologize to his viewers and readers for
his ridiculous defense of the 2020 presidential
election. How many forms of cheating and rigging
does he have to see? He should also apologize
to those anchors who got it right and fired the
ones who got it wrong or were afraid to speak up,
of which there were many. It's time to get rid
of fake news and call it like it is. Fascinating.
Trump now applying his fake news moniker, his
fake news moniker to Fox News itself. It is going
to be a wild primary. My intent is to stream C PAC
today, tomorrow, and Saturday, assuming it doesn't
get canceled like last night seem to get. We
will be starting mid to late afternoon four or 5
p.m. eastern ish today on YouTube, Twitch and
Facebook. I hope you'll join me and remember
all our commentary and videos widely available
on Tik Tok. Search David Pakman Show on Tik Tok.